what
am I the Walmart reader
and I can do the law presentation right
you're gonna do the wall
how you doing Mr chains
no just no different than any other
customer
We Ready gang coming in hot we should
have met him before we started
knock knock what's up how y'all doing
man good all right good to see you man
welcome to the store I'm Mark I'm 2
Chainz what's up
man for sure man little family run
business man listen man you got to tell
me more about what you got going on the
space that you have how long you've had
this space how did it become a family
business okay why are you resilient
how do you know it's a good deal
to buy and know that you can get money
you know in the long run you know what I
mean it's it's a lot to tell me what it
was like during the pandemic it was
something that it how did you become an
expert and and what we got going on here
the like 78 when I was a kid we were
collecting baseball and like 78 to 85 I
was really active in it and then like
everybody else you kind of grow up and
get a real job all right you know and
and during the pandemic uh Aaron and I
were we went to our safety deposit box
stumbled on a Wayne Gretzky rookie card
which is one of the best hockey players
of all time
of course I paid like 25 for that when I
was a kid we sent that card out to PSA
to get it graded and it came back TSA is
a company that grades cards how do they
rank that where does it go yeah it goes
to 10 since it was such an old card
seven and a half so still worth the
decent amount of money so we ended up
selling it for about 2 500 on eBay
okay and we're like all right we're
gonna go buy the goats we're gonna go
buy Jordan we're gonna buy Kobe we're
gonna buy Shaq we're gonna buy Brady
also is that how you because I don't
even know how you saw something we kind
of learned along the way when the card's
not great it's called Uh raw card so
it's let's say it goes for thirty
dollars but if it grades a PSA nine
which is mint condition they call it
it's worth ninety dollars so there's
that Arbitrage in in between and back
then the grading was about eight dollars
and fifty cents a card so you can see
where you can make that money and if the
corners are right if the centering is
good you know there's all these little
minute details
amazing this is our Jordan grid okay
Jordan Grid it's a Jordanian grid he's
the goat he gets his own girl that's
hard pick one you'll pick one you like
all right let me show you man I'm gonna
tell you I'm gonna tell you I know how I
know what I'm doing okay give me one
second
oh let me see I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go
[Music]
I'm going with this card I'm going with
this car that card is a replica that
Fleer made it it's a replica of the
original rookie card which in that grade
would be worth two hundred thousand
dollars so I'm seeing see what I'm
saying right so what's the the most
expensive Michael Jordan card that you
have up here it's gonna be this guy
right here this gold car the gold card
go that's that that goes by Rarity and
there's not a whole heck of a lot of
them we go here click on that you'll see
the pricing of every card comes in
underneath and then what we do is
First We Take the suction we bring it
over here we give it to Aaron Aaron
Rings it up so here's your card oh thank
you
educate me on the Pokemon craze right
now the grading companies are getting
hit with more Pokemon cards than they
are with all the sports cards this is a
2000 first edition Dark Charizard that
card's worth about four to five thousand
dollars right now and they go into the
million because lost origin comes out on
Friday we're gonna get 25 cases out here
are you gonna be the first one to open a
pack oh here we go
[Music]
there you go
that means something I've never seen
this car
watch out watch out watch out watch out
let's call PSA right now and let's see
I know I could do anything with my with
my mind too I can do anything oh
[Music]
[Applause]
it ain't even I'm telling you somebody's
selling this exact card
four thirteen dollars thirteen thousand
okay I think the most valuable part of
this card is that you pulled it
every Card Collector is a treasure
hunter and The Greatest Adventure for a
card collecting treasure hunter is doing
it's when a collector buys an entire box
of card packs to try to find that one
goat card in the series that's what
we're looking for a 200 box might
desield at twenty thousand dollar gem
I heard somebody's from Atlanta and they
like yeah man yes all right here's what
we got basketball wise we got some stuff
about wives no not Basketball Wives oh
I'm about to say they got cards so look
this is 2018-19 then we also got Zion
and John Morant rookie year and then uh
last year's which is gonna be lamelo and
Ant-Man go at it guys
oh yeah it'd be easy and quick I got a
chef green Frank tent
you got more
rip rip you guys keep on ripping I'll
keep up do that right now
we haven't hit the autograph Terence man
Clayton I got the Drone pool right there
oh
[Music]
there you go
all right holy crap I want to look that
up where'd he go here we go we gotta see
how much that's worth look at the um
price on that
it looks just like it
[Music]
are you serious it says my car my car's
worth 25 Grand
man thank you man that's awesome thank
you this joke was worth 25 Grand this
would be one of the best episodes I've
ever shot and then we got some very
expensive cars we got some big time
cards to show you
so how about we start off with Kobe
Bryant
that's a gold card this is a gold Kobe
it's a nine it's nine out of ten
conditions correct it's a 98 version
this is 42 out of 81.
this car
anywhere between 15 and 20 grand bam
exactly
oh my God yeah the first out of 99 with
the Jersey
[Music]
50 000.
he's dead on again you are dead on again
y'all looking at each other
I'm trying to figure out where you got
these numbers from because you're dead
on that's that's right around fifty
thousand dollars yes I used to sell
things and before I got here all right
this is National Treasures National
Treasures is like top of the line Johnny
Walker Blue this is card number nine of
ten the owner doesn't want to grade this
card because every day he takes the card
out
and he smells that pigskin
that's real peace smell that baby isn't
that good so that's why I won't grade
this card because this is my favorite
card
isn't that good oh man this is a monster
babe I don't even believe that's real
that is real I don't believe this is
real it's authenticated and certified I
don't believe this is real yeah a babe
might be worth about a half a million or
250 between 150 and two I got something
crazy for you
wow all right so this one only 250 in
the world wow this is from O3 I could
tell it's from O3 it's 10 out of 10.
there's only nine in that condition that
card is worth about a third of a million
dollars right now okay and he paid 900
for that card
wow man
foreign